je peux vous dire que kelly b de vesly
n'aime pas eric mendez eric mendez que
j'adore qui est notre chauffeur de salle
je pense que cette personne me dit ça
peut-être parce que je demande et muscat
la cub
quand il les connaît pas ces mineurs bon
alors bab el may cry jean michel maire
devrait se contenter de commenter les
clubs échangistes et rien d'autre bah
oui sauf que j ai pu depuis à peu près
quinze ou vingt ans où j'ai pas non plus
été les centaines de fois donc je
préfère commenter quand même la clique
médias parce que ça je connais quand
même tout petit peu plus mais s'il faut
aussi remettre je permettrai ins et où
l'anglais vous est insupportable quand
vous criez par contre bravo pour ta
tolérance et on franc-parler respect et
chapeau massa c'est bien simple est
alors insupportable quand vous priez
c'est vrai la tolérance le feront pas
mal à bravo c'est qui ça line co de lyon
bravo l'ico de lyon exactement ce que
j'ai fait c'est vraiment qu'il y vit de
veliki balance les jingles aller voir
les jours voilà donc c'est aléatoire des
façades et recettes en moins souvent
c'est pas moi mais ça peut arriver pour
tomber sur la bonne émission
madame fraises benjamin castaldi devenu
aussi gênant que j'étais redresse de
force le trait quand il danse pour faire
rire alors
venez juste gêné pour eux et leur
famille bon bref c'est pas danseur maxi
j'ai des danseurs sa soirée un chère
madame crise donc casting est aussi
gênante verdez voyez plus j'ai donc plus
de malaises ont aménagé tout ça m'excite
guény qu'occupe dont se fait penser mon
petit cousin des mutants qui est perçu
vivent toutes ses dents c'est vrai
j'adore danser la macarena aussi tu que
tu que tu es tu as tellement de choses à
faire
le jour où une émission plaît à gilles
verdez jeux prince la tête marasme à la
tête alors chers anaïs parce que cache
investigations toutes les émissions et
plaza
ça fait déjà tout non pas trois mais
voilà alors faudrait qu'elle soit autour
de la table
je reçois énormément ce type de tweets
sachez que je suis et pas nui à ma place
je me plais très bien
j'y suis de temps en temps au tour de la
table justement j'en profite encore
d'ozanam idriss excellente émission jean
michel maire le meilleur temps je ne
sais pas qui est douce à la maîtrise
mais je le gêne déjà c'est très gentil
je te fais des gros bisous à
l'excellente émission c'est l'émission
qui était très bonne et quand tu es
derrière dans le sillage d'un génie du
paf comme si lionel astier que tu as
même plus besoin de battre les ailes
tout de suite là cette année derrière
le concorde toute l'âme voilà en tout
cas c'est très gentil
je vous embrasse tous et benjamin
castaldi arrête la présentation était
pnt pour se consacrer à qom et j'aime
j'aime bien le bourg il met le bois
toujours très drôle non je n'en ai pas
je n'arrive pas en revanche les côtés
comme j'aime